OH! Plan time to chill! Welcome, Welcome to the Corridor Crew channel!
You've caught me recovering from a epic adventure. My backpack was really heavy and my back hurts now, so I'm stretching my neck.
My back and it's just not deep enough.
It's super easy for all of us to burn out to go week upon week after week after week of making videos.
Living life taking care of family hanging out with friends.
it's very, it's a very fast life keep that up for too long and,
Something's gonna happen explode into a fiery bits or no your anger will come out on to your friends and to your wife girlfriend boyfriend.
Whoever and you wouldn't know I mean, maybe you'd know
Get upset a strong word, um, my my stress and anxiety will come out on to friends my girlfriend
My stress will kind of carry over into friendships or relationships
And that's not cool. So how do you take care of that for me?
Personally it is to take breaks and to meditate to slow down to go for a walk
Talking about dropping what you're doing
Going on an epic adventure my good friend Tyler. He's the guy who called me up was like hey Clint
"Do you wanna build a tank? " And I was like,
"Yeah, but took us a year to build a tank out of cardboard. "
It's always random when Tyler calls me because he asks me some ridiculous questions
Such as, "Do you wanna climb a volcano in like a week? I'm down for anything. "
"I'm down to go on to any adventure, get in trouble a little bit. "
Let's just do it and then if you get in trouble just be like," I'm sorry. "
Yes, this will be my second volcano the first one in
Indonesia was for a yoga trip for like nine days to just do yoga. It was with a group of people
I've never done anything like this before I didn't know what to expect
Never been to Bali they were like, all right, guys, we're doing a volcano pi3 the morning
It was a sunrise hike all of the like dirt and sand it was just like ash
Every step you take you're sliding down another step. So you got to take big steps. It's an intense hike
Hey beautiful sunrise there were monkeys up there. Yeah. Yeah, but they would steal your food
They stole my friggin pancake. They stole my bananas, but there were cute little guys
Oh great. Great little guys. So that was my first point. I gotta switch sides
Oh
That's that that's that left. Oh that's that left side I said left side stretch
Don't get mad when your body stops wanting to work because it only makes it worse
It only makes it harder and the best thing you can do is keep moving forward
except this is what you're in this is the state you're in and there's no way out and you put yourself here and you got
to keep going forward and be okay with it if you can control your mental state in those times of
Difficulty and those times when you like you want to give up that's like the ultimate challenge for me for me personally
We're fortunate enough to have be given vacation time
Yeah, if you don't have that that luxury like you still need a check out, right?
Yeah, what if you're like your job is that stink? Can you do that?
Is it worth it? That's a super top. Well, what's the worst thing that ever happened to you from Forgetting a password?
I was locked out of PayPal accepting like freelance jobs
And I couldn't get paid because they shut down my PayPal and like locked it up password was wrong or something
I tried again. It was like security requests are the worst
Yeah
Like what was your pet's name a sponsor of today's episode is last pass the leading online
password manager already used by millions encrypts all your passwords with a master password that only you know
You don't have to write it down or hide it in a wall
You don't have to get locked out of your bank account and not be able to use it
You just need to keep that one password in your head and that's it
Have you yeah, and now we're sponsor
Eddie in the wild you've been thinking about getting it
Yeah, they they store your passwords and you only have to remember one password to get into that one
Well, that's automatically log you in two things are yes, it's a Chrome extension. Oh
It's the next. Oh my gosh
So all you do is you use the extension and then if the extensions on and you're logged into it on that browser
You go to Facebook. It'll be on your account so I can have it home
I can have it here can have it on my phone. Yeah, of course. You've lost $200 from forgetting a password. Yeah, okay
When Nico and I went to New York when we met with Shawn and Peter McKinnon and we all won those Xboxes came back
And I knew and I want to play some zombie games on xbox
But I had to sign up you get that Microsoft Live account and I forgot about how you can't recover
Anything if you forget some things I forgot my password, so I try to sign in and then they go you can't sign it
I was like, okay, how can I recover it? Well, I'll try to change password
Well, you have to go through the submission form to change your password
Are you an email saying we don't have enough evidence to prove that this account belongs to you?
It's been going on for months and each month in each month. You're the $10 charge 10 bucks. And yeah, I've called Microsoft
if you use LastPass
It'll keep all your passwords in a password vault and it will encrypt them all
So that it's all messy and only you on your end have the code to decrypt it
And then you just use a master pass for everything since I've come up with a similar solution
I have a notebook hidden in my wall
That has every password every username to every single account that I have ever made
Right the way that you deal with this is by taking a pen and paper
Writing them all down on the notebook and hiding it in your inside of your walls
What if some house goes in there I got cats?
the apartment catches fire
through their master password
System and encryption algorithm LastPass relieves the trouble of getting locked out of accounts and the anxiety that comes with that
So it keeps you sane
You don't have to write remember or reset passwords real real simple if you guys are interested in signing up for LastPass
Just go on down click the link in the description and tell them corridor digital sent ya
Talk to your boss like yo, I've been here putting in my hours working hard
I want to be working my best for you and I feel like I'm burning up feel like I didn't even a vacation
Do you understand? You can't expect someone to sprint forever just be like I'm doing this for you. I'm teton it
You not really can take a break take 2 weeks go with your family go with your friends go with your girlfriend go to boyfriend
No, go go alone. Traveling can't be expensive plane tickets hotels
I like Airbnb what what I do
honestly
Just take a chunk of my paycheck put into travel savings and you save up for travel so that way
you're not killing yourself when you pull out that travel money traveling taking breaks are as important as
Your diet like your mental health is just as important as your physical health
Let's talk about how was the the hike up that ball came out with Tyler just the essentials in my backpack
Water snacks. The first part was like shady forest
Everywhere there were mosquitoes. I hate mosquitoes for about 2
Miles to a half miles you're saying deer run around
giant evergreen trees and then we finally come out to this like little like plateau area where you saw the volcano way in
Background wait way over there
changing out some film
Just finished my black-and-white roll. No, I'm on Seville via 50
There's anything worth taking a picture I've happened here
Probably not. I mean I was gonna take a picture of my phone get a nice
planes rolling hills
You look down into this valley
There's like a lake and then in the distance, there's this huge like Zelda Mountain over here
It was incredible smelled like Christmas smelled like very crisp fresh, err
and we get to a checkpoint and then we start seeing snow where
There's lake and there's a glacier up. It looks like one was there
Well, we got like another two hours to go
We chilled out there eat a couple apples and Clif bars and have some coffee and chill out. It was beautiful
We chilled our champagne in the ice
Because of course gotta bring champagne for the top and then we hiked across this like snow field
We packed up and we head across this like this ice valley climb up to the very top and there's this breathtaking view
Alright dude where we going
So yeah slow down plan time to chill even when you're chilling, all right, I got your 30 push-ups
I
Challenge all of you go on an adventure of some sort this year whether it be a weekend trip a week-long
trip or a two-week long trip go on an adventure floor the area around you be there be in that moment drop your
Responsibilities forget about Instagram. If you can't I know it's tough. Come back
Write about it. Go back through all your pictures really really just enjoy it, you know
Enjoy it enjoy that vacation and then send us some pictures or tweet at us
Instagram at us
however
You got to get at us
Send us a message and let us know what you did what you learned what you felt and if you're gonna go on a vacation
Again, Oh
Was that good
We can fix it